[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I am
in Amsterdam and boy are we having a
good time I like Amsterdam so much that
it makes me do my happy dance
the natives laughter amused laughter or
embarrassed for you laughter I think
they felt ashamed yeah crazy American
just just ashamed that their city would
attract someone like me Hank we've done
a lot of things in our first seat as an
Amsterdam one of the most fun things we
did was go to the Contemporary Art
Museum here we see the videotaped
encounter of a spaceman looking at the
Buddha and the Buddha looking back at
the spaceman this piece made me want to
do this dance for some reason that was
weird on our way out of that museum I
got so excited that I started doing this
[Music]
Hank when I first found out I was coming
to Amsterdam I thought it would be kind
of like a drug-addled den of iniquity
you know that it would be kind of like a
dirty debaucherous place like Las Vegas
but with legal lead but it turns out
it's one of the cleanest most beautiful
cities that I've ever visited it has
lots of beautiful green space
everyone bikes everywhere and when they
don't bike they use small efficient cars
even the toilets are ecologically
friendly even though English isn't the
first language the graffiti is
surprisingly thoughtful there are lots
of beautiful fresh flowers and the
people are so friendly that even when a
business is closed they want you to come
in and all of the buildings are
beautiful
including the shopping malls and in fact
the Yeti and I have been talking
constantly about how we can move here
although as I do keep telling the Yeti
Indianapolis is truly the Amsterdam of
central Indiana it's all enough that it
makes me want to do my happy dance some
more
the things I do to entertain you Hank in
summation Hank it seems to me that
Amsterdam is like a lot of great cities
will be 50 years from now it's efficient
sustainable and mostly underwater Hank I
have very limited internet access but I
hope I'll see you tomorrow